my name is justin reich i'm a research
fellow at harvardx just down the road
i'm also a lecturer here in eric's
sheller teacher education program where
i teach undergraduates who want to be
6-12 math and science teachers
and i'm a lecturer at the harvard
graduate school of education we're in
the fall i'm teaching a class called
massive the future of learning at scale
and i've sort of immersed my my original
background as a ninth grade world
history teacher
and spent a lot of time teaching and
sort of blended hybrid kinds of
environments and have been excited to
see
you know what's probably drawn me to
this field more than anything else is
just the incredible excitement that's
happening around harvard and mit about
teaching and learning in a way that sort
of the like craziness of the mooc hype
with sort of all of its problems and all
of its complications and difficulty has
made it just a super exciting time at
these institutions to be talking about
teaching and learning
i was asked to not talk for very long
and so that'll be my goal is to really
throw out some provocations of
you know what i what i hope to have a
conversation with you about is where do
we think the field of open online
learning research is right now
what kinds of things are shaping that
field what kinds of you know elements of
the sociology of research production or
the incentives in research production
might be having us create certain kinds
of things and not create other kinds of
things and particularly interested in
what are the things that we could be
doing or ought to be doing more of
but we can't because there's not the
right funding or they're not the right
partnership so there's not the right
incentives or those kinds of things
and in in
um
in sharing all this you know i've sort
of subtitled the talk um you know four
types of mooc research pep talk to
myself you know i don't mean to at all
be claiming
that i'm independent of those kinds of
incentives or factors or you know i or
we at harvard x have been doing the
right things
what i really want to talk about is some
of you know in some ways like some of
the pressures that i feel and the
directions that i feel sort of pushed to
move into
and the places where i think they're
sort of harder higher hills to climb
that might be more rewarding if we were
climbing them but ultimately you know it
doesn't really matter what i think it
would be great to try to have a
conversation among everyone when we do
when i stop provoking and we do get to
have a conversation someone's going to
be passing a mic around and they've been
really really
they've asked us as a community to be
really good about passing the mic and
making sure that we're talking into them
so the other people who are watching
this later all of whom are desperate to
hear your ideas
can uh can hear them clearly
i figure if i pander to your uh
that's probably the way to do it so what
kinds of things isn't being done or
isn't funded
a b testing focus on community formation
and social learning personalized and
adaptive learning are the most important
neck directions not enough research
funded around scale and sustainability
comparisons of blended learning
flipped models versus traditional
classroom models versus traditional mooc
models to the extent that there is a
traditional mooc
what are uh i went to the i went to the
university of virginia and we had some
saying which is like if it happens once
it's a coincidence if it happens twice
if it's a tradition and if it happens
three times thomas jefferson himself
ordained
that we all ought to be doing it
design research and then collect data
not the other way around
thoughtful research pose a hypothesis
design course such that data can be
collected to help answer that question
a conversation about demand side how are
credits earned through moocs perceived
credentials
are we putting the car before the horse
scaling interactivity having more
research on exist based on the existing
education literature with a
concentration on what properly can't be
studied in a small class so that's sort
of looking for areas where we can offer
a kind of value add
given online learning is a
multi-disciplinary endeavor how do
people from area a and area b get
together to understand the funding
landscape in each other's fields and to
write fundable proposals that's a great
response
though not the question you can neff
what can we learn from the mooc world to
improve the educational experience on
campus what affordances does this new
environment bring how do we capitalize
on the capabilities first how applicable
is mooc research to traditional courses
randomized controlled trials not just
from people who sort of own things but
from other places what kind of learning
is taking place
better tools for instructors qualitative
research conversations with learners
good
so those are some of your ideas
here's here's one of the ways that i
would try to organize them
so i've thought of mooc research is
happening in kind of four categories
fishing in the exhaust experiments and
the periphery observations in the field
and design research in the core
and let me define these four pieces and
talk about where i think our biases are
so i think most if particularly over the
first year
i'm proving much more this year a lot of
the initial mooc research has been what
i would call phishing in the exhaust
sort of drawing on computer scientists
reference of the data streams or
admitted by systems as exhaust so
someone made the comment about sort of
running a bunch of courses and then
doing coming up with the questions to
ask afterwards
i think for a lot of good reasons that's
been the bulk of stuff that we've done
some of the reasons that we do it are
because it's really cheap
and really easy it's a lot easier to
just you know get a pile of data and
start doing analyses on it than to
develop partnerships with course teams
in advance to be able to make other
kinds of opportunities available
and you know you can also get result in
some once the data is available you can
get results pretty quickly out of that
data um i think there are some some
limits on what kinds of causal
inferences we can draw from these kinds
of data in a lot of cases although
there's lots of kind of exciting
quasi-experimental efforts
i also think that it's very very easy in
our field to believe um
that the data that we have access to
summarizes the full experience of what
we're seeing when you're looking at sort
of a pile of big data it's easy to
believe wow we have you know millions
and millions of records how can we not
know everything that's happening
but of course you know what what we see
people click is only a fraction of the
experience that they're having and it's
often a proxy for the things that we
care most about
i would say the sort of next field which
has been most kind of expanding from
from fishing in the exhaust kind of
studies which is what i spent most of my
first year doing
with what i would call experiments in
the periphery and i would and i'm
defining the periphery
in terms of the experiences of the
people who are developing the courses so
i would say
most of the experiments that we have
running in our harvard x courses right
now have a couple of qualities to them
so the first is that they're domain
independent they're not capable of
giving us insights about the science of
learning in any particular discipline
we're not learning about you know core
ideas and the instruction of biology or
core ideas in the instruction of physics
we're looking at things you know mostly
about improving people's motivation and
engagement
that would extend across lots of
different fields so we're doing things
like um
there's a guy named todd rogers who has
a really neat study buddy study where we
get people to give us the email
addresses and sms numbers of
non-cohabitating friends and relatives
and we send them an email once a week
that says something like hey justin's
taking the ancient greek hero and this
week he's been reading about how oedipus
gouged his eyes out why don't you ask
him about that um and then so you
basically sort of create these kind of
conversational prompts to get none it
turns out it doesn't work particularly
well with cohabitating relatives because
your wife already has 99 things to nag
you about and like the um if edx is the
100th it won't help you very much but
your uncle doesn't have that many things
to nag you about so if you get him to
have these conversations
these kinds of experiments typically
require sometimes they're advertised as
requiring no involvement at all from the
faculty or the course developers so
they're developed by some kind of third
party researcher they're designed to be
applicable in any possible field and to
be dropped into courses with sort of as
little friction and energy as possible
and you know i think this characterizes
actually quite a bit of you know i think
part of the expansion of these things is
because we we're at a particular moment
where we've had a lot of insights from
social psychology a lot of insights from
behavioral economics
you know the sort of technocratic
researchers have got super excited about
nudging and priming and guiding and
getting people to opt in and opt out and
things like that
and then if you know if you're someone
who's been who's been looking at a bunch
of mindset interventions and you're
thinking yourself man you know there's
seven million teachers in the us like
it's a lot of work to go one at a time
to seven million practicing teachers in
the u.s and say here's how you do this
intervention and here's the right
language and here's the wrong language
and here's what's fidelity looks like
it's super attractive to be able to say
oh i'll just program this experiment
into this platform which reaches lots
and lots of people
you know in the sort of sexiest of these
experiments have uh um
have
seemed to take very little time they
seem to have lots of long-term impacts
you know there's a whole lot of focus
and if you're trying to get them funded
you sort of have this promise like it's
going to be cheap it's going to be you
know have long-term downstream effects
and we can do it at scale because we
have these platforms now that make it
possible
so if you would if you were to look at
the portfolio
of experimental research that we're
doing at harvardx you know which is sort
of a growing field almost all of them i
would call experiments in the periphery
in the sense that they don't have to do
with either figuring they don't really
have to do with
seeing if we can improve
elements of disciplinary learning in
fact in most cases we don't even really
use learning measures as an outcome at
all we use persistence or participation
or certification or those kinds of
things
so i mean i think in the next couple of
years we're going to be have see an
explosion of that kind of research and i
think it's going to events all kinds of
really fascinating questions
you know one of the main ones really
being um you know what what's the risk
that we're accelerating learning
experiences which actually aren't that
beneficial for people to begin with um
there's a great yogi berra quote which
is something like we're lost but we're
making great time um you know like
you know i mean if we don't believe you
know if we're not sure that a learning
experience is providing meaningful
learning opportunities for people is it
ethical to be accelerating their
participation in it and then i think
there's a whole bunch of great like if
there's a gazillion researchers and
platform developers who have all gotten
certain like super excited about
embedding nudges and primes and these
other kinds of things like how are they
all going to interact with each other
what's going to happen over years when
students get exposed to these kinds of
things over and over again what kinds of
diminishing effects will we have
so i think there are a lot of good
questions to be asked there
i would say
again you know i think our portfolio of
research at harvardx is not that
different from what i see sort of
happening broadly in the field but if
people disagree with me i'll be excited
to hear that um
this uh
um so one category of
of research that i see very little of
are observations in the field um trying
to find out um qualitatively i think
we've done there's a lot more kind of
survey research that's happening but in
terms of trying to understand what are
the experiences that learners are having
particularly things that we can't
capture um on our platforms let me
skip 90 of what i was going to show you
because it's not that interesting um
i'll go back to some of it there here's
we're lost morning time um
so here so so here's here's a series of
figures that we've been producing that
we think are kind of interesting so on
the x-axis
is each video in one of our courses so
this particular course had 297 videos or
something like that and on the x axis
they're numbered from 1 to 297. um
the light gray line is the number of
people who started the video the the
black gray line is the number of people
who finished the video
the red line going across is the number
of people who earned a certificate
so one of the things you can see there
is that by about a fifth of the way
through the course you see the
intersection of the number of people who
finished watching the video each video
and the number of people who earned a
certificate um i think you could see
this pattern i mean this was a pattern
that i noticed from the very first moocs
that were offered like if you went to
600 2x um and looked at the very very
you know they got you know seven
thousand or so people earned a
certificate if you looked at the last
dozen or so videos there are three or
400 people who are watching those videos
not every course that we have has this
pattern but an awful lot of them do
you know the other thing that i would
say is that a certificate earner is a
pretty you know conceivably a
conservative estimate of the number of
people that we think ought to be
watching a video we have about you know
about as many people who are engaging in
sort of auditing like behaviors um
trying to learn from experience without
doing assessments as we do who are
certificate earners so you so i mean you
can the red line is just a reference for
like how many people should be watching
these videos and you can move it up and
down based on all kinds of things that
you believe
but i think it's pretty hard to dispute
that there seems to be a pretty huge gap
between the number of people who we
think ought to be watching these things
and the number of people who are which
raises a bunch of questions like so okay
how are you learning this stuff
some people might be downloading
transcripts and right now edx doesn't
pick up that event so we're missing that
some people might be reading the
textbook that's associated with it
some people might be talking to their
friends some people might be banging
their heads against problems and just
figuring it out on their own
some people might be looking for you
know i had a student who i once
interviewed about her learning
activities in college courses and she
said i think most of my lectures are
terrible i sit and i listen to them and
i write down keywords and i look them up
in wikipedia later
and that might very well be a pattern of
practice
but all of the kinds of learning
experiences that or i think there's a
whole suite of learning this suggests to
me that there's a whole suite of
learning practices that we're not
capturing or understanding on the
platform um and that one of the most
effective ways to learn about them would
be to pick up the phone or get on skype
and talk to a bunch of these people and
say explain to us your learning
behaviors you know and this sort of is a
proposal for
you know there's an issue of people that
i'm most interested who are the folks
who are finishing courses you know
engaging with less than 25 percent of
the learning materials that we that we
think they ought to be engaging with and
what kinds of things are they doing and
how can we figure more more out about
this um
so this to me is sort of like a
particular prompt of there's a whole
bunch of learning behaviors that are
happening maybe online but uh
but off platform and maybe sort of in
the real world entirely um i had a
colleague remy mansfield who's now at
edx who helped me do a few initial
interviews this past year one of the
things he was tapping into is people's
help seeking behavior what kinds of
things do people do when they're looking
for more help and he found some people
you know these are all idiosyncratic
one-off kinds of things but people who
like basically got people together for
drinks on friday nights who had
expertise in the area that they were
taking and sort of creating these social
events
where they could learn from the other
people around them um people who were
talking about you know what kinds of
resources they had in their networks
that were social capital that could
support them that we'd be totally blind
to
so i think um
you know i think there's huge promise
in
and i think it's hugely important for us
to do some of this kind of observational
um research and you know and it's
interesting to me to start thinking
about you know why aren't there why
aren't there more mixed methods kinds of
studies why aren't there more
opportunities for
us to really think about what kinds of
things are happening
that the platform will never pick up on
and then to me what i think the hardest
kinds of research to make happen
in our field certainly to make happen in
harvardx or what i call design research
in the core
and this is research experiences where
we're trying to use as outcomes the most
important learning outcomes of the
course no matter how difficult or hard
they are to measure and where we're
testing the most important pedagogical
propositions that an instructor brings
to a course
that research that has the potential not
just to sort of advance the science of
motivation and engagement but to advance
the disciplinary science of learning in
particular domains
there are a number of reasons why this
is super hard and i think rick clark
this morning alluded to some of them so
one of the reasons is it really does
require multi-disciplinary teams
and it requires these multi-disciplinary
teams working together under really
difficult circumstances so most of the
you know i would say harvard x maybe
maybe there are other places that are
like this but but my office i have a
sort of little glass wall and a door and
right out in front of me are two tables
full of course developers you know like
i can throw things at them if i want to
talk to them they're they're right next
to me um
but they but
they are incredibly time constrained and
having you know they have a lot of
pressure to put together these enormous
courses under relatively short time
frames um they're super interested in
doing research but asking them and
particularly asking their faculty
members to be involved in the research
design process from the very very
beginning you know one of the things
that rick pointed out is that for you
know working with a lot of instructors
you know asking the question what are
your learning objectives one of your
learning outcomes um
my colleague sergey nysterko used to
joke that sometimes we'd ask these
questions of faculty and it was like you
were sort of
talking to a wounded artist or something
like that like what do you mean the
learning objectives i would teach
it was not just european exactly who did
that the full range of people who did
that um
but uh
um you know and so going from there to
okay you know what instruments do we
have to measure that if we don't have
the instruments to measure that how we
change it you know one of the things
that's been fun for me over the last
year is seeing faculty thinking about
what their learning objectives are
really evolve
so i would say you know particularly
strongly say in the sciences
we found that you know if you asked a
lot of science faculty why they were
teaching
the beginning of the course
you know they would say things like well
i teach fundamentals of neurobiology and
here are some things you need to know at
the fundamentals of neurobiology if you
if you talk to them about a year into it
they a lot of them say more things like
look i know the vast majority of these
students unlike my harvard students are
not going to go on to be neurobiologists
what i'm really interested in is
figuring out if i can help them better
understand the scientific method if i
can help them appreciate and be critical
consumers of science news media if i can
help them you know increase their public
support there's their support for the
public funding of science that they
basically have as many kind of
behavioral affective outcomes that they
have from their course sort of social
justice kinds of outcome there's a
course we're about to launch on
education policy
where i think the professor cares a
little bit about whether or not they
leave knowing what no child left behind
is
and knowing some basic kind of public
policy theory i think he cares a ton if
they leave the course knowing who their
school board reps are if they go and
vote in their local election next time
if they pay attention to community
issues
there's a whole research on civic
education that i think could give us
some insights about how we could start
measuring some of those kinds of
behaviors that are that are really more
behavioral than effective in nature
but i think there are i think doing that
work has a whole series of challenges
it involves this kind of coordination in
a ton of fields it involves developing
new kinds of assessments and measures
it involves making substantial changes
to the architecture of courses and
conceivably not just a b testing like
you know oh what if we make the button
really big or what if we put the hint
before or after the problem but things
like you know so so here's one from
introduction to computer science um
cs50x from harvard starts with a unit on
scratch starts with a unit on black
based programming
that doesn't require syntax or language
you sort of drag bits of code together
to program they don't really know
whether or not it's a good idea to
introduce programming using block-based
programming languages
it would be almost the only way you
could test it sort of you can't a b test
kids at harvard because they're a little
sensitive to these kinds of things
and so you could sort of over many
multiple years
offer different kinds of curriculum but
one of the things that we could do in
cs50 if we had enough time if we had
enough resources was launch people into
you know randomly assign them to two
different courses one that starts with
block-based programming and one that
doesn't say we genuinely don't know
which of these approaches is better so
neither of you are getting you know
we'll know pretty soon if one of these
is better than the other
but at the moment we don't there's one
course that did that so copyright x
was a sort of a spock kind of an
application course with 500 people where
they had one course that was mostly a
globally focused curriculum and another
course that was mostly a u.s focused
curriculum
and they randomly assigned students to
these two conditions at the end of it
they decided they did a better job
teaching the u.s focused curriculum that
even students from overseas preferred
having a coherent introduction to one
intellectual property regime than trying
to figure out what was going on across
the world
but obviously you know i think that also
gives a hint of kind of the difficulty
of some of these sorts of challenges
building two entirely different courses
training your tfs to run two entirely
different courses
but ultimately i think that's where uh
i think i think particularly if we want
to do more than advance kind of the the
science and motivation and engagement
but really you know to advance the
science of disciplinary learning we're
going to have to do these kinds of
experiments that closely involve content
experts
some of the things that i think
disincentivize that in addition
or all of that kind of design work
takes much much longer to do
than grabbing a data set and looking at
it afterwards
or coming up with an experiment which
even if the sort of smaller experiments
of periphery take less time you can drop
them into four or five or six or seven
different kinds of courses
and and get more data and more results
that way um and i don't think there's
nearly as much you know i don't think
there's new
i think i think this is an area um where
people who have the power to control
incentive systems might be able to make
a real impact like if i was a funder in
this space right now i would be thinking
you know how can i fund this kind of
design research in the core which a
young postdoc is much less likely to
decide to voluntarily engage in if
they're competing against other young
postdocs
who are going to focus on sort of
cranking out papers that they can with
the data sets that are available
or how if i was a person who is managing
course development in a university how
could i get how can i prioritize you
know letting people put their courses on
edx if they agree to make research
design a kind of fundamental part of the
architecture of the course and not
something that you can kind of choose to
do if you want to
in year two or year three
one of the ways that you might
sort of summarize some of this to put
some of these things on some dimensional
scales and then i'll stop and let people
talk about whatever we want to talk
about
is to say that i think if you look at a
lot of the research that comes out of
the you know and tons of which which
i've done and i'm fully participating in
i think was useful for lots of reasons i
think a lot of the fishing in the
exhaust well you say you know the left
right axis here is from more
observational research to more causal
research or at least research in which
it's easier to draw causal inferences
although there's all kinds of clever
things that you knew and then sort of
borrowing gears and other people who who
don't know what to use and sort of use
as crutch words this idea of thin and
thick
the idea that
that that there's certain kinds of
research we can do that has much more
texture
and in particular has much richer
context about the learner and much
richer context about the particular
course and about the particular
conditions
and i would say you know my read of the
field
is that we spent a lot of time in the
top left corner
and we're sort of moving to the top
right corner
and i'm really excited to think about
ways
that that we can that we can
particularly figure out how to move into
the bottom right corner how can we
try to do more work
that really understands the context of
the learner that really understands the
context of the course that asks the
hardest questions that we can possibly
ask
about the about disciplinary learning
and advancing disciplinary learning
and you know and incentivize people to
take on those kinds of toughest
challenges
but that's my read and you all might
have totally different things to say so
why don't i stop um and uh you've heard
i can sort of put back up here
i think we have a microphone
you've heard what some other folks think
are sort of the most important things to
talk about i took the opportunity to
have sort of the first words about that
the other thing i'll say so two things
please do talk into the microphone um
and i'll try to facilitate in a way that
unless that i don't need to answer the
questions other people we can just have
a conversation among the people in the
room that i don't have to respond
particularly to any of it
hi i'm ursula wools
my background is rich and varied and one
of the things that i did do
is i went on a dog and pony show with
dave mallon about teaching scratch first
and so there is published literature on
the fact that teaching scratch first
works better
and it's based on
a model that or a context that i don't
know that i'm happy with is it what we
looked at as retention
and we also looked at
whether it was attracting a more diverse
audience and um
let me put this from it from the
trenches the way that we did it and a
special interest group for sig for
computer science education conference at
a 60 conference is that david got up and
he said i did two weeks of scratch and
then i taught harvard major c
um and then henry whose last name i've
lost because i haven't seen him in about
five years he got up
and said well i do this at harvard with
java
and everybody everybody in the audience
is from from middle tier and and small
colleges and community colleges and
they're all going yeah that's harvard
and then i would get up and say and i'm
doing it at the college of new jersey
and they all go okay this is doable and
so what we have is a body of anecdotal
evidence
through interviews of people who have
tried this and it's been successful
i love your your paradigm is wonderful
because i've been an observer in the
field
and
my dilemma is that i have good results
of using of teaching online courses of
my own design
um i have
a little jury rig platform that i use in
in in google sites because i can't use
blackboard because i'm dyslexic and
blackboard is not supportive of people
who reverse things easily
and i've also used
moocs in my classes
i can't share any of that with you guys
formally because i never got irb
approval
to ask my students or even track my
students or even collect their data okay
so i i'd like i'd like this conversation
to be a little bit about that is how can
you bring more of us
into the conversation about what data
is valuable okay now you still have a
good research question because david and
henry and about two dozen of us know
that if you start with a syntax free
language and then move into a formal
programming language you will get
amazing results and more to the point
you will get more non-white males to
stay in the courses and take the next
course mark boost house built his career
on that concept
but how do the rest of us engage in this
in a way you know we don't have the
research funding to do it we don't even
have the mandate to do it and we
certainly don't have the ability to work
through an irb and do everything we need
to do to set up a clean experiment
no really really good questions i know
if people want to respond to that or
which is a rare event um
so i guess i would disagree a little bit
that an irb is a tough thing to get
because this technically
yeah i mean irbs are
you know they're not anybody's
idea of fun
but or if yeah but um
you know this would this falls under
educational research so you can get
really sort of very easy exemptions um
so you don't it's not like doing
a an intervention with
you know a medication uh so
so we get why don't we let her finish
because she's got the microphone and
people won't hear you yeah so um
so i mean in some ways that gets to the
motivation piece right to the
persistence piece to the grit or
stick-to-itiveness of what we're doing
so when you're doing your
curriculum design if what you think
you're going to do is
educational research then you build that
into your structure before you do it
yeah i think that's exactly right so one
of the things that we're trying to do
institutionally at harvardx is number
one have really close relationships with
our institutional review board we
basically you know we have an
institutional review board member who
comes to all of our meetings we either
pretty regularly
a second thing we do is to try to build
structures that you know that push the
limit of
making our protocols as applicable to as
many courses as possible and extended
over time as possible and obviously irbs
try to reduce that to some extent so
there's some tension but for instance
for some of the interview research we've
done we've tried to set things up
so that
you know
by default in all of our pre-core
surveys we ask people to opt in to being
interviewed
and so that's at least one initial step
of we have a sort of solicitation that's
out there we try to have sort of you
know default irbs that allow us to um i
think trying to think ahead of what what
are the kinds of research that somebody
might at some point want to do um and
try to make it possible so to me there
are two issues right which is how do you
operationalize your research project
right i need an irb i need this i need
these right and how do you connect
people in your institution to to do that
type of work and i think the one thing
that people forget about is to look
outside of whatever school you live in
right so
for me um i am partnering with people in
the school of informatics and people in
the um school of education and you know
so it takes a little bit of effort but
it's amazing how many people want to do
this type of work
third point graduate students summer
research students folks are hungry for
the opportunity and they will help you
like you don't have to do it all
yourself yeah no great i think neil had
a question that was in the back and then
eric
hi uh neil ephraim worcester polytechnic
institute um the um i was going to
actually um i was going to actually say
oh i hate your title where we actually
talk about experiments in the periphery
right because we want to actually run
those experiments in the core but i now
recognize that oh you're just kind of
saying well lots of them that have been
done right now have been in the
periphery and you'd want to actually get
them in the core because there's a guy
that actually loves to actually publish
randomized controlled trials and thinks
of himself as an education researcher
i'm like that's the whole point that's
what's going to be really important in
this mooc stuff okay is what do we
actually learn about human learning and
how can we use it to actually do that um
on the irb thing um so we just recently
got an nsf actually award to actually
help 100 researchers run studies inside
our platform rrb is probably pretty
unique uh it's actually not unique
actually oli actually does the exact
same thing
you know
our platform and edx maybe actually
maybe you could speak to this issue
but actually
if you want to do a study inside our
platform with 60 000 kids
you need to get irb to actually look at
anonymized data
and we don't actually do like discussion
board stuff so it's kind of easy for us
to anonymize data
but actually we are actually running
your study under normal instructional
practice uh we don't need any prior
consent
and we work on 13 year olds right uh and
so it's really important to actually
understand the irb context given that
can you state actually
under what circumstances does actually a
edx or harvardx class actually get
qualify under normal instructional
practices such that actually no one
needs to actually sign into something or
does that never happen at harvardx no it
so um all the decisions are made at the
heart at the school level rather than
the edx level um because different
schools have different institutional
review boards that could decide these
things differently
you know everything we do gets reviewed
by an institutional review board um but
we don't have signed consent from our
participants um so we uh we basically
say that
for most kinds of things that we're
doing that look an awful lot like
typical instructional practice you know
we're gonna we're gonna even if we're
doing some experimental stuff we're
gonna give you your readings over three
pages instead of one page we're gonna
you know make a few kinds of changes
like that um we just refer people to the
edx terms of service and the privacy
policy there's probably better ways that
we could do that but that's what we're
doing for now and works for some of the
things where we give people put people
in experimental conditions where they
might experience substantially different
curricula we basically put it in the
syllabus and make a bunch of
announcements beforehand like if you had
taken that copyright x class you you
would have to be pretty oblivious to not
realize that there were a couple of
different classes going on and you were
only going to be in one of them and you
were discouraged from talking to the
other one and things like that so we you
know we work pretty closely we do get
expedited
kinds of reviews
but everything does have to have a
protocol that's written up and does go
through there other institutions could
settle things very differently i mean
that's one of the sort of funny parts of
our federated um irb system
i think eric had the had the next uh
you know maybe one meta point to talk
about the two things that we've been
talking about is um you know to what
extent can institutions build
institution you know it sounds like some
of the barriers that we run into are
sort of common institutional structures
um how do we make it easy for people to
get through the irb how do we make it
easy for multi-disciplinary researchers
to connect with each other how do we
make it easier for graduate students to
find um projects you know for on the
last one we've borrowed a lot of ideas
from the lytics lab at stanford and the
way that they've sort of built community
over there and we at harvardx are trying
to do the same thing
of of pulling in resources um so that
seems like one theme of of obstacles
that we might work on collectively
so eric klopp for mit
um so i wanted to to
your bottom two quadrants of your of
your original slide not that one but
that one yes so the observations in the
field and design research and the core
so i'd like to argue that design
research in the core is only useful if
it's accompanied by observations in the
field um like so thinking of your
scratch example in the scratch example
there um so if you just compare scratch
versus python or somewhere scratch
versus java
you don't necessarily learn that much
other than that those two particular
choices are
better or worse than other for certain
kinds of students
um but if you actually do the
observations in the field accompanied
with those you can understand well maybe
scratch is better because it's block
space as you proposed or maybe it's the
community aspects or maybe it's the
graphical nature of it or maybe it's the
community aspects there's lots of
different things that are different
about those two things and you might
decide that some of them are more
important to people than others and be
able to ultimately design better things
for
for people through
being able to get some of that
observations in the field so how do you
how do you sort of think about
i that was those two but are they is
there more of sort of like a an
ecosystem of these things that exists
where
they they they really only are good when
they sort of accompany each other yeah i
would say one reason why i use sort of
experiments in the top right and design
research in the bottom right is to sort
of subversively suggest that like if
what we think of as experiments which is
not what a lot of really experienced
learning scientists you know neil and
eric and other folks are thinking about
if we think about them as sort of
flipping a b tests like you know you
make the blue button and you make the
red button and you just see which work
better
i don't think that kind of approach is
as powerful as being really informed by
theory and and also i think your point
is exactly right that often that you
know we think of randomized controlled
trials as kind of the gold standard of
research but they're the gold standard
of comparative efficacy research like if
you want to know if a is better than b
this might help you but if you want to
know why
a was better for some people than b then
you often have to talk to students and
find out about their experiences some of
that you know i think we can get out of
fishing in the exhaust i think some of
the things we might be to say wow these
quick click streams logs might really
illuminate the kinds of work we're doing
as well as these interviews as well as
these surveys as well as what people
type when we look at the discussion
forums and things like that so to me i
mean you know i'm obviously influenced
by your work and other folks but my
sense is the people who have been you
know learning scientists who've been
working on this for a long time at the
intersection of education and technology
have you know see
a b testing as one important tool but as
you eloquently described in the context
of a bunch of other strategies
particularly to figure out why things
are operating the way they're operating
and because they operate differently in
different i mean this is why i also have
a bias towards domain specific things
because i think oftentimes those
contexts differ quite a bit from one
environment to another and understanding
how they operate in a particular field
is important although you know some of
my colleagues who are um you know
cognitive scientists and experimental
psychologists get super excited about
the sort of universality of human
cognition um you know and they have a
great case to make that if you find
things that work for all of our shared
monkey brains then like that's something
that can be
used in lots of different contexts so no
i think that's a that's a great point
hopefully helps explicate my language
there a little bit
other people have other thoughts or
questions or
things to look back on
or other things that you think you ought
to be doing some a fifth kind of mooc
research that we're that we're not doing
i'm curious on uh
you know when it comes to like
completion rates and engagement um
a lot of the you know a lot of us are
interested in how you know we're kind of
disappointed with where
things are at and you know are looking
at ways to how to improve those metrics
have you guys done any work where you
looked and and sort of how the students
feel about it like to the ones that make
it further are they happier or you know
the ones that don't do they care like
does it matter so the one so the ones
who make it i mean this is i think a
great question of you're saying you know
what are what are what kinds of
observations can we do of people who
persist at different lengths throughout
the course um one of the challenges that
we had is you know we we thought we were
all clever at harvard x this year and
we're like oh we'll do you know people
have been really doing a lot of post
core surveys let's do a you know some
consistent post core survey so we send
out these course evaluations at the end
of the course about like one and a half
percent of people respond to them
they're the one and a half happiest most
satisfied you know people have persisted
through all these challenges and they're
filling out our nth survey for them
that you know in some ways these
documents are incredibly useful because
you know satisfaction is a 4.9 out of 5.
overall learning is a 4.9 you can hand
these things to the faculty you know and
and they will you know even the social
scientists will conveniently like ignore
the bias that's sort of totally obvious
like you had 90 000 people in this
course and here's 600 surveys that all
say you're great you know and the result
is yeah i am great um
and uh you know but but one of the
things i mean i think this is where lots
of people can partner so you know
there's uh sheriff and probably other
people
at stanford and other places have been
working on trying to predict drop out
you know how do you tell the difference
between someone who's going to take a
break for a week or break for two weeks
and someone who's really done
trying to find the people at the moment
that as close to the moment as we can to
when they're done to get their course
evaluation then and to figure out
you know i've just submitted something
which was i mean it's okay to ask the
question
um you know one thing we've gotten
better at is figuring out what kinds of
intentions people have when they come to
the course but if we really want to
understand completion rates we got to
understand why why did they leave
you know there's there's some unknown
percentage it's probably pretty
consistent across courses of people who
leave because stuff like came up in
their lives and there's probably you
know there's probably some natural
ceiling um but i would say that you know
the
one concern i have about all of that and
i think rick talked about this earlier i
think there's a lot of good physics
research behind that there are lots of
learning experiences that we provide to
people
which do not benefit them um and so
unless you know i mean i think all the
stuff that sort of came out of the
research with the force concept
inventory and all these ideas that
people you know people could get a's in
physics at harvard
and have very little change you know as
rick said this morning you can be you
can be a worst physicist when you leave
one of these courses even if you've done
really well
so i think
having having an entire focus on
engagement and completion rate i think
there are some good reasons to do it and
we participate in that work and get
excited about it but i think if we don't
have more of a focus on are students
actually learning um you know if we
because there may be some trade-offs
there we may find that you could do
things that increase the amount of
learning that people do that also
increase your um dropout rate but that
still might be worth it to get the folks
learning who you want to be learning um
that to me is like one of the big
missing holes
that
you know i think dave pritchard is doing
terrific work in this area where he's
really trying to use a bunch of
well-validated instruments he's a bunch
of well-validated concept inventories so
he can make some claims not just about x
percent of people finished my course but
i think they learned this much um
which a lot you know and some and this
is harder in some fields than others you
know we have this course the ancient
greek hero where the essential question
is what does it mean to be human um like
that's a tough one to you know write
multiple choice questions around and
things like that um but uh but i also
don't think it's you know not i mean i
was a history teacher and so i'm a
humanist at heart but i'm not you know
i'm not one to sort of throw my hands up
in the air and say oh it's impossible to
measure like there's got to be some
things that we can get in there i could
talk about more of them someone out here
had that hi my name is el wong from
columbia teachers college
thank you for your talk and i have a
open general question to the audience
also
i wanted to know that as a researcher
and instructor myself um
i want to know why do we care about what
kind of research we want to do and
what exactly is our goal like
do faculty members really care about
improving completion rates if the course
is you know free
and open access
if it's offered again
what's the significance of improving
their completion rates and what is the
significance of making students happier
even
and from a research point of view
do we want do we just wanted to you know
explore the data and to know whatever we
did not know before
or do we
as researchers maybe you're representing
addicts coursera you're representing on
a department institution what what are
some of our goals we want to
you know try to explore rather than just
you know faced with the huge excitement
of this you know mooc thing the data and
everything just really open question
here and we also have a
panel
at two o'clock on motivation and
engagement so okay
i don't think they may want to respond
to anybody who hasn't shared anything
emily do you want to or uh
oh yeah sure a couple replies from
people who haven't uh yeah i would just
add to that by saying you know if it's
not generalizable to a context where
the rest of us can be making better use
of it i think i think your point is
really well taken and it's a question
that i've had the last couple of days as
well so i appreciate you asking that
okay would you say more even more
specifically what i think i know what
you mean by that well you you know i the
the fact that you've got a very specific
kind of an audience that's engaged in
these moocs the fact that um they've got
particular their own particular goals or
lack of goals in these books um as
compared to
um you know we're very interested in in
exactly same kind of questions
i'm sorry university system of maryland
um i'm the director of the center there
at the system level for academic
innovation and of course we're very
interested in understanding the answers
these questions for our students who are
engaged in credit bearing courses who
desperately need
increased access increased availability
of these courses we want them to be able
to to to benefit from these sorts of
things we're interested in the answers
those questions but in a
somewhat different context yeah so the
opportunity cost of your students is
another emily might be the next person
the opportunity cost for your students
is another they might take another
course you know the opportunity for cost
for most of our students is like they'll
go and watch the wire
um or other kinds of things like that um
so they're you know to do do students
who are
you know probably mostly affluent for
the for sure mostly you know
already degreed students already
successful autodidacs are the kinds of
things that we're learning in these
environments applicable to other
settings and in what kinds of ways and
how can we test that and you know i
think it gets back to one of one of the
people who who added to the uh poll
before it sort of raised this idea of
like what's and it connects to this like
what's the particular value out of this
research like what could we be doing
that can't be done in other kinds of
contexts which would be an interesting
thing for folks to riff on
um yeah i guess i can just say quickly
sort of some of the stuff i was thinking
i've already said but that
for me to serve design is always the
reason that we're doing this work and
it's designed both on the pedagogical
side and the technology side and i think
it's
a lot of the tools that we've been using
in classrooms and in distance learning
settings are
somewhat limited compared to sort of
what the the entire internet has
invented in the last 10 15 years um and
so i think one thing that's really
interesting about moocs is sort of what
it what it draws from how the web does
things broadly at scale with some a
little bit maybe more interactivity um
with what we're doing in more
traditional classrooms and i think when
we're we know more about who these
students are what's holding them back
and what's not if there are some things
that are more generalizable in terms of
say you know learning strategies or
social supports that we can
then adapt into the platform or into
different types of technologies um
then that might that's that's a reason
to to do this work to understand these
contexts and understand how these
contexts are different than other
contexts and whether those differences
are salient or not for the design
choices that we're making because they
might not be and they may be but that's
we have to keep comparing and looking
outside of this particular zone
tim you want to go ahead and then
yeah go ahead
oh what do you want to do and then
you can go next time
thanks so um a couple of thoughts that
harken back to the talk this morning is
um i really would encourage us to think
about the educational literature so sort
of why to do this scholarship you know
ernest boyer many moons ago talked about
the different types of scholarship and
the different types of of you know um
how do you approach it so it's not just
like did you like my class right um it's
it's what's the purpose and
and why do we do it so
people may want to look at that work
before trying to reinvent the wheel the
other thing i think about in terms of
how to do this researcher at what level
if you think of this as a drug trial
right so it's a drug intervention i.e a
massive online learning experiment
and you have phase one trials where are
we gonna kill anybody with it okay no
we're still in phase one right now we're
not killing anybody right then the next
trial is sort of a phase two well what's
the best dose and how many and how long
and for um you know and then you move
forward into in what situations in which
population which group does this
does this intervention work best in um
it's just a different way to frame it
for yourself so that that we all just
don't feel like we're whistling in the
dark right because this really is there
is a science behind it and if we think
about it purposefully like that i think
that will help guide us um you know you
guys all talk about a b testing and i
actually i'm like oh that's a randomized
control trial that's just it's just an
rct and so if you think about
if we if we
put it in that context that may help us
uh frame our questions that's great tim
did you have uh
on something else or anything else you
want to talk about
yeah i want to come back to the
implementation of research from the from
the start and from the core so i'm
working for a european mooc platform and
i mean we already have some research
stuff like a b testing we have surveys
you can implement a lot of stuff to the
course most instructors don't so the
question would be but is it a problem
from the instructors or are there really
tools missing
on on mooc platforms that should be
implemented without them
research cannot be conducted
um i'm a computer scientist i'm not a
learning scientist and that was a
deliberate decision back in the dark
ages but i was a research assistant in
the mit logo lab and the one study that
came out of out of that project which
has had an influence on on so much
computing education
um it was the brookline project and this
was my role and again this was back in
the dark ages and i'm i'm
let me preface this with
i challenge the learning scientists and
the and the instructional technologists
in the room to really think hard about
how you can create better observational
tools in the mooc environments this was
my job
okay we had four computers and four kids
in 1978 this was unheard of
and what we had was something called a
dribble file you guys call it a click
record
okay my job was to sit in the back of
the classroom while dan want a brilliant
teacher
worked with four children
and i took notes furiously with paper
and pencil because we didn't have any of
this cool technology of what was going
on in the classroom
and then after they all cleared out
and the school shut down and i had
finished hacking scrap
logo because i loved it as a tool to
play with
i would print out the dribble files
and i was required before i went home at
night i didn't always do that but before
i went home at night i had to annotate
the dribble files and explain what was
going on there and we had an incredible
rich body of information about what the
kids were doing on the computer and what
the kids were doing off
i don't know how you translate that into
to 21st century so we
so we have a uh we have an irb protocol
that i haven't found any students to
work on yet but our idea for that is
basically to sort of borrow for instance
some of the work that like sam weinberg
has done at stanford on think alouds and
things like that where we
we have everything in place to be able
to invite
our students to do an interview with us
and then after doing an interview with
us to do a study session where they
broadcast their study discussion with us
through skype or google hangout and we
record it
and so it's one way of starting to
figure out like okay so what are they
doing off platform like who are the
people who wander behind them and ask
them questions like what does it look
like and how noisy is the coffee shop
they're in are they in their classroom
are there in their schools um and then
it would you know wouldn't be hard at
all for us to sort of time stamp those
video records and correlate those video
records the to the transcripts and to
see what they were actually doing on the
platform and things like that i think
there's a whole there's a whole bunch of
stuff that we could learn by directly
observing people's practices either
doing what you did which was observing
people's practices sort of totally
naturalistically totally at a distance
saying just you know do whatever you're
doing and we'll watch you to the extent
that you can
you know something is unchanged when
it's watched which is not um but the
other thing we're thinking about is also
asking people um to think a lot as
they're doing some of these practices to
talk to us out loud and say you know
what are you thinking why did you make
that choice just keep sort of narrating
what you're doing um so you know some of
these things are
you know and i would say part of the
part of the challenge for
um
it would it would be i mean i i don't
know how this is across other kinds of
institutions but there's definitely
you know i think some of it is just
trying to convince people to raise the
value of that kind of research
and say that we can do all the sort of
fancy things we want with log files but
that our view of them may be really
incomplete unless we get some of those
other kinds of things
tepo joe tennis for medic so
talking about the question of
how do we when we have these fancy tools
how do we get faculty to use them we
definitely
wrestle with this challenge and one of
the things we've started to learn and
hear feedback from
is actionable things that there are some
faculty who really want to do
research for the sake of it and
especially those who have background in
it earlier somehow related to learning
sciences but we've heard from many more
people that if we are able to give them
analytics tests that they can in quick
succession somehow use to modify their
teaching or add
other interventions in discussion forums
or by email that they would use them
more so that's at least something that
we're then now furiously thinking about
that how can we quickly
give something that's actionable and we
are hopeful that that will get people
started put their toe in the water and
then maybe do more and more i think
that's a great suggestion sort of
thinking about research design thinking
about how do you how do you make your re
so your research design has intermediate
conclusions that come quickly enough for
faculty to be able to do something with
it so when you're pitching it to them
you can say don't just do this you know
for the good of humanity when we figure
out this a year from now but uh you know
we'll have things set up so that in four
weeks we'll be or two weeks or whatever
it is we'll be able to give you some
sort of suggestion
yeah once i suppose one other thing to
mention is uh the value of uh not just i
mean a b testing sort of implies that
there's an a and a b
but very often
uh kurt lewin basically brought us the
two by two where you vary uh where very
very two factors and why is why is that
so important well it's about because it
helps you figure out the why question
which which susan told us at the very
beginning of this conference is so
important to figure out
uh and so
that gets difficult sometimes because of
the the sample size especially when you
do it a little bit later in the mooc
especially when you then want to figure
out
well it might work this one might work
but for whom right when you then break
people out by that pre-core survey that
only 10 of people took
for that one condition that was already
split up into four we there's basically
not enough data and i've run into this
multiple times uh in my research i've
done several experiments in moocs and
what i've what i found to be a good way
to
to proceed in that case is to have the
same study run in several moocs and
really coordinate with other researchers
to to try the same intervention or
whatever it is that you're researching
because that way you also get greater
external validity by trying out in
different materials with different
populations that can be studied and for
that to work
effectively we need to come up with some
standards
what are the what are the ways we
categorize learners what are the
questions we ask them at the beginning
to then be able to say my learner
population this course looks like this
your learner population looks like that
let's let's see what the difference are
in certain groups let's let's see how we
can match them to make some causal
claims or quasi-causal claims i think it
would be good to to come up with some
standardized standardized metrics that
we use
to do that
so we're about out of time maybe i'll
maybe i'll end with sort of my final
here's a final pitch for why i'm
particularly interested in disciplinary
learning
and it just has to do with sort of the
sociology of groups so my read of what's
happened across k-12 but also across
higher education is that when is that
you don't change faculty you don't
change university you change tribes um
as i think about the kinds of influence
that i could have you know which is
extremely limited over harvard faculty i
think the odds of my research no matter
how good it is no matter how certain we
might come up with of sort of changing
faculty practices i'm not sure that
faculty change their practices in
reaction to new truths coming out of
educational research i think the primary
thing that changes people's practices is
when they see people in their tribes
doing research that finds new practices
and things like that
and whether that tribe is statisticians
or biologists or physicists or humanists
or social scientists or whatever it is i
think i think maybe one other
kind of case for disciplinary learning
is that i is that i ultimately think the
people who adopt a bunch of these best
practices it's not going to be across
whole fields it's going to be in very
particular disciplines and so the
possibility then exists that if you can
say here's an impact that we had in
statistics courses here's an impact that
we had in public health courses here's
an insight that we had um in public
policy courses
it might actually be a better vector for
change to think about sort of changing
one tribe at a time rather than trying
to change universal you know rather than
trying to find universal truths and
convince universal faculty um to to
adopt them so that'll be my sort of
that's my my i'll leave you with that
final pitch for
design research in the court which may
be that argument may be wrong but
thinking about one of the things we came
to is not just how do we do this
research but how do we do this research
in a way in which it actually leads to
changes in practices
and there may be there may be ways that
we that we rethink our research
strategies as we start thinking about
the final mile to how we get you know
the modal teacher in the modal classroom
to adopt the insights that would be that
would be most useful well thanks for
sharing these conversations if you want
to keep chatting with me i'm
here all the slides i didn't do because
their signs are boring
so you can find me in all these kinds of
places
and uh and i'm happy to continue the
conversation thanks for spending some
time with me